today we're going to talk about how to
not end up with this like none of us
want to be the one who ends up without
dataviz on WTF it WTF is because we
screwed up the analysis or because we
just didn't know what was going on
without data and kind of let our results
guide our results kind of dominate all
of our sanity checking so what can
actually go wrong without data right
well but we've all seen the XXV example
but we don't we kind of forget that its
geographic data and if you do for
geographic data and don't normalize
you'll end up with geographic data so
but you need to understand if your daily
needs to be normalized needs to be mean
subtracted there needs to be some kind
of processing to it to get it to Ackley
represent we're trying to look for
another thing that can happen often is
you're missing data right if you're
missing like half your data then you
albums are going to break I think you
might get great results right you know
how you get the most fantastic
correlations ever you lose your entire
data set because if you have a
correlation of two points the two points
it's going to be like a hundred man arms
and the other thing that can typically
happen is so this this is the result we
wanted we merely wanted to prove that
forecasts or a great job of predicting
climate the only problem is this was
buggy code something was shifted and
this is completely artificial remnant of
the code itself and has nothing and has
nothing to do with whether the actual
technique whether our model really does
a good job of predicting a result right
and so the question is where should we
start this was a gift arm right because
we can be really flooded with lots of
information and we just like buried
under it and often times it can be
intimidating you know I'm given a new
data set and I just don't know what to
do yeah I usually stick this let's just
you know pipe it through some machine
learning algorithm get some great result
don't do that
um song with me search Wikipedia is your
friend you want to know kind of where
your data is from who produces it what
your data is right if you're looking at
um some new like if you look at primates
wiki primates just see like what are
they and the reason you do this because
you want to know what it like the
typical values what are the typical
patterns there is nothing new Under the
Sun even if your data is brand-new
something similar probably exists and
what you want to do is right it's get a
feel for what's existing arm going on
because about 99% of time that new
surprising thing you found it's not that
you do something cool and found
something awesome it's a you screwed up
and we're trying to avoid the results
due to school right so always research
your data and get it like enough of a
grounding food so that when you're
talking to other people you can be like
I'm looking at you know crime rates in
malaga and the way we compute this is we
find this like arm you know we got this
data from this database and etc arm step
2 python is fantastic right we all like
ipython notebook and I don't know when
nobody does this but print your data
right if we have one of these self
documenting datasets write a CSV now
with pandas we can get a lot of our
column information i have 0 information
we can like know what's in our data
before we plot with it netcdf sand HDFS
are the most fantastic file formats
because they try to be self documenting
so right we can load in our data and
just stop putting out the attributes
start printing out your column names
again this so you start knowing what it
is you're working with because say I
didn't pick this out bike and I just
plotted it well what dimension would I
plotted step three is to actually plot
the data so this is just a pot right now
what's wrong with this well you guys can
guess right there on the labels
so I label it great and student ID
here's a problem is this this data is
actually independent right so it looks
like a great pattern like hey the date
is cyclical but the X is independent of
the Y and so this is complete nonsense
so now we're going to actually be
arranged out data and so when we store
our data it looks like your typical
grading curve right and so step two is
that one is just like thorpe a plot
realize you're screwed up the two ish
thought rearranging your data because
it's arm not dependent and you're going
to end up realizing oh pattern expected
pattern and here's the thing right if my
powder if didn't didn't look like this I
was out getting worried because this is
this typical distribution for grades
like if I saw like I see a wheel dip in
the 40s so I'm like okay did I invite
somebody's waiting wrong or did I or did
something weird happen over there and
that's where you start the excavation
when you're going to high dimensional
data right like we were talking about
like cures temperature data just pour
one location one will be shown there it
doesn't even matter what what you're not
looking for here is like van global
conclusions what you're looking for here
is what does my data look like on a
basic level and so here I know my data I
learned my data a sinusoidal and it
should be its temperature data
temperature seasonal the sinusoidal if
I'm not reading in my data as sinusoidal
from one place on earth again it's just
like my Vita is wrong my data is wrong
something went horribly horribly wrong
and you want to catch and it might seem
silly but you want to catch all these
things in the early stages right because
you don't want to be like presenting
this big fancy visualization well that
has some glaring out because you didn't
catch little mistakes of first place and
so by step one will plot out of time
series another thing we'll do is we'll
plot of dimensional data and what we
learned here is the world is upside down
here's what we really learn like when
we're working with client your typical
climate data set the world
is upside down they run it from the ant
article down and so you have to know
this when you're doing analysis if your
analysis is at all depending on where
things are on earth right and so what we
will do now is will collect it so
everything is even but we want to have
this knowledge of so today's going on
here one have this knowledge that we
learned that our world here start in
Africa it's a zero to 360 grid we learn
that when a negative 92 190 you know we
see our typical pattern you know like
the equator is supposed to be pretty hot
the poles are supposed to be really cold
if none of this shows up again you
screwed something up here the other
thing we're doing this is because what
we want to see is better Center is the
same kind of logic of this is Antarctica
Antarctica is the opposite of us their
hardest in January their coldest in our
summer if we're not seeing that she is
no pattern in our snapshot we haven't
aligned outfits correctly do that we
also want a histogram pistol them to
your best friend here's why what if I
want to apply shiny model to this the
date is not Gaussian half the models we
use a Gaussian right so if you haven't
checked that your data is Gaussian
before applying your model to it there
is no reliability that you could also
correct so you always want hips to them
absolutely this is a weird semi bimodal
distribution which you'll find is
typical and stem courses but you want a
histogram i'm also always take the man
min max mean median right I know they
sound basic and you're like oh this is
so boring why is she talking about this
because I keep working people who they
don't do these basic things like they
don't know what the mints on their data
they don't know the Maxis the means or
the medians and so they give you these
like fancy things sped into logistic
laughs so Gaussian regression you know
fancy machine learning soup and you
can't verify that there is also accurate
because actually no then you go back to
that data and their data so broken so
those results fantastic not great though
so why do we do this to two reasons we
always want to check the mean and the
median because of outliers life because
medians are means or more sensitive to
outliers so if your means and your
medians are really different from each
other then you know you're going to have
outliers and they're going to be
schooling up I think like half the
algorithms out there you want humans and
you're Max's again to get a feel for
like what are my typical numbers like
what's going to kind of seem out of
range if I had somewhere in this globe a
map that was above 310 I just found that
some where on earth is abnormal arm
abnormally hot and it could mean two
things it could mean that like hey
global warming those low could mean a
temperature sensor book but we want to
be able to do this kind of basic you
know what kind of what am I expected
numbers here one of my normal pictures
look like for this and this is all fun
but when would happen to it light will
have too much datum what like will
almost be fighting with it because we'll
have these basic rights all that stuff
is basic but I haven't gotten to this
data is multivariate like I've just
given you one day one month again you
one day one month I given you these tiny
snapshots of time but I haven't helped
you characterize what all the data looks
like and that's important to write
because you're not just looking at this
single you know this is like a start of
the picture but it does it weighs the
bowl this is doesn't tell you where in
the data it's broken doesn't tell you
that somewhere along the way the data is
broken this just tells you well it might
tell you like something's broken but it
won't tell you where how and that's the
next step right we want to be able to
detect what voc where and how and so
we'll start looking at multi valued
relationships arm here with this is
flood data and we're looking at the
relationship between all of these waves
and groundwater like we'll look at how
all of these are pairwise compared to
each other arm it's a scatter matrix
because what we're going to do is this
is again we want to end up feeding this
into a model but before we feed this
into a model that is based on the idea
that these things are related to each
other we wanted to say hey is there any
chance in hell
actually related to each other right so
we'll feed in so first we actually
explore our valuables we see a haze
anything related to each other and it
looks like no but if we look at them out
of flood what we learn this hey these
are bimodal not then we completely like
there's a one there's a zero and that's
it so hey that's a class so let's take
our data again let's recall of it so we
now have class based stuff well guess
what all of our floods kind of cluster
in one region now that we've seen that
we've you know in a basic just scatter
plot where we've colored it so that we
can highlight our classes we've seen ok
there is evidence we might be able to do
a classifier might be effective because
we see flood data it's in one scattered
typical Legion everything else is kind
of there too and around the other thing
want to do those like white high order
stuff so clustering algorithms are a
friend arm and here you're not doing
using closely albums to find like what
are typical patterns you're looking
closing plan is to confirm known
phenomena like in this case biomes this
is precipitation data and what we did is
we just cluster the time series of
precipitation data and we colored it and
we found biomes environments are just
typical geographic regions that fit into
one their typical geographic regions
they that have one kind of temperature
pattern but climate microclimate major
climate actually pattern and so a desert
so all kind of together which means our
data doesn't do anything good with
desert it mountainous regions arm pretty
dry and so will confirm this by actually
then looking at the cluster means when
we look at our cluster means yeah
deserts pretty dry we have a lot of vein
in the highest vein fall is that bright
yellow color which is like Indonesia and
the top of South America so we'd want to
go now back to Wikipedia and confirm
hate is that is that where we kind of
usually see the hot I'll just rainwater
because basically you might find
something cool and interesting and new
but to do that you need to be able to
reliably tell people that I bed my data
incorrectly I know what my data is doing
right arm the other thing we're going to
so this is one way to look for non Paris
another one is on look for structure and
this is where the PCA and the LGA and
come and write your dimension reduction
algorithms arm and so typical life we'll
look at will applied in this case to a
seasonal data set because again we
expect will break out two seasons this
isn't so useful though right because you
feel like that we seem groupings and we
expect whoopings because seasons so then
we'll color it by month and seasons um
which i guess is the other sub thing of
this talk right we know about season so
we can use them to color data to help us
see that the patterns we expect out
there are always use outside knowledge
if you expect your data to be grouped in
a certain way you know build that into
the coloring of the class rank of the
pca or whatever technique you're using
to kind of do your preliminary
structural integrity checks like if this
data you know and so what I learned here
is hey there's a weird little outlier
and that might be fun to explore further
arm and we'll use some we can use some
later signal filtering whatever to try
to find out what's going on with those
outliers but otherwise we want to see
this consistent patterning going on arm
and then you can you know control your
own data okay that was absurdly short
wasn't it questions yeah
ah God my favorite was when they were
doing like a logistic regression on
model data against the thing being fed
into the model so yeah and by the way
this happens all the time I think that
I'm kind of doing that with one of my
projects um that's actually what you
found with oh actually that's the poking
picture I just threw up here yeah um oh
oh you mean um actually both of these
this one was fun because the guy we were
working with was how do i do a full
screen ah so this one arm was the one
getting great correlations I'm like
inundation and DVI because you're
missing most of data and if you're
missing half your data your correlation
start looking great a lot of the time
it's almost by probability um this one
is actually an example of that forecast
climatologists used to put in forecast
models like the linked climatologist fed
into forecast and the observations are
fed into forecast two months back so I
shifted my forecast two months back so
if you try to do hey how good is a two
months but back forecast that's based on
two men back data at predicting to my
back data yeah you'll get great results
um but not terribly interesting those
are some of my and then I member
actually the first time I ever looked at
netcdf file I can tell everything all
zeros and I was like hey something broke
I didn't know I understand that CDF um
and it was like one of those were the
data is packed with a format with an ad
fact and a scale factor
and yeah other questions yeah yep yep
yep
well one the ones I love and we don't
have it I didn't couldn't find the
figure of it but we did arm the GPC p1
is precipitation modeled and we did we
do the clustering on both dimensions
once we cluster it over space and we'll
make so we'll do it over time and I
would say so this is like if we cause to
it over time and then we'll plot the
clusters and the other way we'll do it
was real close to it over space so that
each observation in time is a say each
observation in time is an observation is
a cluster and then we plotted that like
the occurrence of clustering like how it
fits into the class arm like kills
cluster 1 + 2 1 cluster to you know the
time series of which observations in
which cluster and doing that we found
that one of our class was completely out
and so then we looked at it and it was
that was the day they changed over
satellites so a lot of times like
clustering can help if you do it you if
you do it kind of multi if you do
clustering along multiple dimensions and
like just visualize all your feature
vectors um you can often that's often a
way to kind of help with the Heidi
problem because you can now inspect it
for multiple ways and again that whole
like an outline cluster can usually help
you detected something go long with
something cool happening
yep thank you like I mean this is 2d I
can make this treaty trivially right but
of what I find white is true like once
you get the 3d you have to vote eight it
to see anything and once you get past
and this is kind of a 3d 74 Z because
the colors are giving you seasonal
formation but like once you get further
than that like most people just can't
understand the visualization so it's
like I can give you the fanciest heat
map tree-length blush you know desktop
but if like it's not going to go into
your head you're not going to see the
problem anyways yeah
no I mean yes or no but in pandas you
can use the cross validation techniques
if you're doing their models um if
you're not doing handles like I just had
to write my own linear regression and
then sandy check it so a lot of that
it's like going back to okay this is how
a linear equation works these are what
the coefficient are going to come out
I'm going to feed in my fake data I'm
going to get out my fake results um so
you have to unit test your own code
which I know nobody does um Oh
technically technically I'm one of my
favorite stories of this is like the GPC
p data which is one of these like big
metadata e science data like so
documenting type I mean I know I said to
print them out but this guy is a great
story like this stuff is what do you
suppose we'll just pull the valleys
right from the data put it up whatever
they were filling in random values so
like none of the metadata actually match
the data um and sound like that happens
all the time um and then there's also
like that weird like it's known in the
community that the data is broken in
just this special way la you know talk
to people it's like oh I was to miss out
a little bit pokud you know so you can't
so and they use this boundary to
validate they assimilate the data which
it's a little bit biased in this way
which is used to yeah like every
community kind of has their own special
sauce and publishers have to know it
which is part of that whole again
researching your data because you'll
find a lot that there's stuff and how
the data is aggregated and you'll be
like oh I found something cool and you
were constantly broken and like yeah we
knew about it here you just do this by
this formula here and it'll all work out
which is really the heat map problem
right because everybody who like I'm
fine right because everybody who works
with geographic data long enough knows
that hey you have to normalize and
everybody who's the newbie to geographic
data is like I'll gonna make a strain
ed3 visualization of Twitter data so
it's um so lot so that goes back to you
know like look at what other people have
done and what kind of analysis they've
done to their data because a lot of
these pre possibly makes are pretty like
common along every but along communities
other questions
you